MALE SPEAKER: [HAPPY SIGH]
And I got to do it, man.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Why in-app payments
are important?
Well, as you all know, users
like free applications.
However, you need to make
a living out of your work.
Life is not as easy
as it seems, right?
For that, we've got your
covered with in-app payments.
You can see it in
many examples-- Clash
of Clans, Netflix,
Spotify, and many more.
In this episode,
you'll learn how
to perform common in
app billing operations
for your Android applications.
In-app billing is
a service hosted
on Google Play that lets you
charge for digital content
or for upgrades in your app.
You can request product
details from Google Play,
issue orders for
in app products,
and retrieve
ownership information
based on your user's
purchase history.
Google Play provides
a checkup interface
that makes user interaction
with the in-app billing service
seamless.
It provides a more intuitive
experience to your users.
So now you need to set up.
Before you can start using
the in-app billing service,
you'll need to follow
these three steps.
Add the library that
contains the In-App Billing
API to your Android project.
Why?
Well, it's the definition
of the interface
that in-app billing expose.
This will enable us
to call its methods.
Then, set the permissions
for your application
to communicate with Google Play.
Last but not least,
establish a connection
between your application
and Google Play.
Now, you can place
products for sale.
Before publishing
your application,
you'll need to define the
product list of digital goods
available for purchase in
Google Play Developer Console.
Once your application is
connected to Google Play,
you can initiate purchase
requests for in-app products.
Google Play provides a
checkout interface for users
to enter their payment method.
So your application
does not need
to handle payment
transactions directly.
When an item is
purchased, Google Play
recognize that the users
has ownership of the item
and prevents the
users from purchasing
another item with
the same product ID
until it is consumed.
You could also query Google
Play to quickly retrieve
the least of purchases
that were made by the user.
To ensure that in-app billing
is functioning correctly,
you should test the application
before you publish it
on Google Play.
Early testing also
helps to ensure
that the user flow for
purchasing in-app items
is not confusing or slow, and
that users can see their newly
purchased item in a timely way.
Want to know more?
Follow the links below.
Until next time,
eat your vegetables,
use in-app payments, and
listen to your partner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]